>> Anne McLean: Good
evening and welcome.
I'm Anne McLean from the
library's music division.
We are very excited tonight
to present the world premiere
of a new work by Brett
Dean, Rooms of Elsinore.
And it's wonderful to have
the composer here with us.
Welcome.
>> Brett Dean: Thank
you very much, Anne.
>> Anne McLean: And you've come
from Berlin for this week here
at the library and our pianist,
Juho Pohjonen has come on a run
out from Finland, I believe.
>> Juho Pohjonen: Yes.
>> Anne McLean: That's great.
And this is your first
time at the library.
You said I think that the
Santa Fe festival had helped
to introduce you?
This is new?
>> Brett Dean: That's right.
I mean I think we have
Marc Neikrug much to thank
for us coming together and for
this commission coming about.
And so Juho was a guest
of the festival last
year for the first time.
>> Steven Ovitsky: Yes,
just this past summer.
And Marc and I were talking and
for the last couple of years,
working with Anne
and the library,
we've been planning this
commission and this concert.
So, the premiere is tonight
and then we'll play it again
in Santa Fe with
both of you in July.
>> Brett Dean: Yeah,
that's right.
>> Anne McLean: So, let
me step back a moment.
I didn't get to introducing
my colleague, Steve Ovitsky,
from the Santa Fe
festival and we are pleased
that you have brought with
you a number of friends
of the festival tonight.
>> Steven Ovitsky: We have about
25 board members and spouses,
partners, supporters, who
are here from everywhere.
I mean many of them live
in Santa Fe year round.
We have a couple here from
Savannah, one from San Francisco
who just came in for this.
So, our board and our supporters
are all over the country
because we exist in only a
six-week festival during the
summer and so they come in for
the music and we're delighted
that so many of them came along
to hear this concert tonight.
>> Anne McLean: And I know
that commissioning has always
been an important thing
for Santa Fe, just as it is,
of course, for the library,
but you presented-- commissioned
and presented the string
quartet we'll hear tonight,
String Quartet #2, And
Once I Played Ophelia.
We're looking forward to that.
And Tony Arnold is
just an amazing singer.
>> Brett Dean: Absolutely
astonishing.
Yeah.
>> Anne McLean: So,
when was this?
A couple years ago?
>> Steven Ovitsky:
Twenty-fourteen.
>> Brett Dean: Twenty-fourteen.
>> Steven Ovitsky: Yeah, in '14.
The piece tonight-- what
Brett didn't mention is
that not only did he compose
it, but he's playing it tonight
as well and-- but in 2014 we
commissioned the string quartet
that you'll hear with soprano
and we also commissioned--
we've done a number--
over the last seven year--
six or seven years, Brett came
to us once as a violist and we--
then the next year we
commissioned a piece,
I think a string quintet?
>> Brett Dean: Well, I've
always had my viola with me.
>> Steven Ovitsky: Yeah, I know.
>> Brett Dean: And the
previous commission was the
string quintet.
>> Steven Ovitsky: The quintet.
So, this is the third piece
we've commissioned from Brett
and that's pretty close to
a record for the festival.
We've commissioned about 75
pieces over the last 42 years
and we do about two
or three a year
and you are probably the most
commissioned composer right now.
>> Brett Dean: I
feel very honored.
>> Anne McLean: You know, for us
it's exciting to have you here
because you join a
very distinguished line
of composer performers
who have performed here
and one was Paul
Hindemith in 1937,
also playing his own viola
music, and of course many other
like Copeland and
Bernstein and so on.
So, as a conductor,
composer, and violist,
we're looking forward to
sort of chatting for a moment
about the whole picture
of the state
of the art of the viola today.
You have the big
perspective on everything.
But before we get to
that, I wanted to ask you
about some of the manuscripts.
I know that you and Juho had
a moment yesterday to look
at some manuscripts,
including the mansion builder,
which you can see in
the cases tonight.
This is a fairly recent
acquisition by the library
and I understand you made
a discovery of something.
>> Brett Dean: Well,
yeah, I mean there was a--
there's a spot in
the third movement
that has always struck
me as slightly odd
where the piano has this
beautifully rhapsodic moment
in the trio section
of an otherwise fairly
tumultuous scherzo movement.
And the viola just has these
sort of pizzicato notes
that go up the A string.
And I was keen to
look at that very spot
and sure enough there's an
extra note in the original
that we're going to
put back in tonight.
>> Anne McLean: Tonight?
>> Brett Dean: Yes.
It's a first.
>> Anne McLean: This is
a-- this is exciting.
I'm glad we're getting
you on video.
Anything that you noticed, Juho?
>> Juho Pohjonen: Well, I
noticed in the first movement
that there was a-- one spot
that actually had bothered me
for a long time because there's
a transition to the B section
from the A section which happens
very abruptly and I discovered
in the manuscripts that
he had a longer transition
for like 16 bars worth of
music which he removed.
So, that's why it
feels very sudden.
>> Brett Dean: Yeah, and then
when you know what his
original train of thought was,
then somehow the suddenness
of the transition makes complete
sense because you see, no,
he went down that
path and realized, no,
that's not what I mean.
Yeah.
>> Anne McLean: So, you never
know what you'll discover here.
I remember once George Schulte
came to look at some manuscripts
and he went out with a big smile
on his face and somebody ran
after him in the hall and said,
maestro, what did you find out,
and he-- he said, oh, I found
something no one has ever
seen before.
He didn't say what it
was, it was either, but--
>> Steven Ovitsky: In the
manuscript-- so, is the--
is that transition then
crossed out in the manuscript?
>> Brett Dean: Completely
crossed out.
In fact, never fully
worked through anyway,
but he just then crossed it out.
Yeah. And I mean I also found
it fascinating discovery
in the Schonberg quartet, which
I'm not playing in tonight,
but have played on
previous occasions.
And the famous line
in the last movement,
which is also famously the
first sort of free atonal piece
that Schonberg ever
wrote and to the words
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I feel the air of other planets.
He shortened that transition
as well by a whole bar,
such that the impact
of the chord
in the quartet is followed
much more immediately
than in the final version
where you've seen him scribble
out a bar by the
soprano coming in.
And so he realized then
also that it needed to--
the shock of that
moment needed to,
you know, result more quickly.
>> Anne McLean: I didn't know
that you had seen
that one yesterday.
Well, you know, as long as we're
talking about this, let's shift
and go talking about the
Schonberg we were thinking
of talking later, but Steve,
you have talked about this too,
how lush the piece is and
I know that it's a work
that as you say had a
very personal meaning
for Schoenberg himself.
And what for me was so
striking was this contextual
juxtaposition of the Stefan
George expressivist poetry
that you're quoting and
then the strange quote
of the [foreign phrase],
you know, in there.
But you were talking about the
harmonic aspects of the work.
>> Steven Ovitsky: I was just
saying that when I talk to some
of our board people who
are mostly non-musicians,
but deeply in love
with chamber music.
And sometimes when they
see the name Schoenberg,
they get a little--
they still after 100
and some years get
a bit frightened.
A few years ago, we did
a remarkable performance
of [foreign phrase]
with the arions
as the main-- the
quartet in that.
And it brought the house down.
Everyone just really loved it
and I was telling
our board people
at dinner the other night how
this quartet number two is
in that same cut.
It's that same very
ultra-romantic style.
It's just before
the atonal style.
And how passionate a piece it
is, especially since everything
that was going on in his life
that helped him or that--
didn't help, but sort of moved
him to write this quartet.
It was a very difficult time
in his life when he wrote this
and that they should sort
of relax, forget the name,
forget what they think
they know about Schoenberg,
and listen to it as
a late romantic piece
and then it makes sense to them.
>> Brett Dean: And, if I
may, it then makes sense
of how the atonal thing
evolved because you then see it
in the context of these
three previous movements
that are getting more
and more extreme,
including as you say this
sort of bizarre, you know,
folk tune in the middle of it.
And then you see that the
lift off of the last movement
into a completely, you
know, tonal free world--
although it's still quite
tonal in the end still
in F sharp minor as well, but--
oh, F sharp major then,
but it makes sense.
You see that he could
only go that path.
>> Steven Ovitsky: The one thing
about this program tonight is
that rarely do you hear a
string quartet with soprano.
Tonight there are two of them
and the two best
ones that I know of.
I don't-- are there any others?
>> Brett Dean: There
are several.
Yeah. Yeah.
I'm sorry?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
I think but piano as well.
The--
>> Anne McLean: Dover Beach?
>> Brett Dean: Dover Beach, I
think it has piano-- and piano.
>> Steven Ovitsky: Baritone.
Yeah.
>> Anne McLean: This
is a beautiful program.
I mean it fits together
so well and has such--
so many threads running
through it.
Before-- and I want
to talk to you
about your Shakespeare universe
that you've been
inhabiting for quite a while.
Before we leave the
Schoenberg, I wanted to say
that our colleague found a very
interesting photograph that's
on display out here, which
I didn't even know we had.
Apparently George Gershwin
was a big fan of Schoenberg.
I did not know that.
And this was a photograph
that he arranged to
have commissioned.
It's very, of course,
austere, you know,
Schoenberg, what he looked like.
>> Brett Dean: Yeah, he
never smiled I don't think.
>> Anne McLean: Yeah, yeah.
And on the-- apparently Gershwin
liked the quartets very much
and he subscribed to
their publication and then
on this photograph you'll see he
has transcribed a few tiny bits
of music from both the first
quartet and the fourth quartet.
So, it's just a bit of--
you just never know what
you're going to run across here
and it's fun to unearth
these things.
But we have so much to ask you
about about this new piece,
Rooms of Elsinore, and
also about the fact
that you have been really as
I say inhabiting this world.
How did you become so
involved with the work
of Shakespeare's Hamlet?
Well, about seven years
ago, after the premiere
of my first opera, which was
based on an Australian novel
by Peter Carey called
Bliss, it was performed,
among other places, firstly in
Australia, then also in Hamburg
and the Hamburg production
was seen by the--
at the time the managing
director of Glyndebourne Opera
in the U.K. who then approached
me to write a second opera.
So, I mean I must say one
of the trickiest things
is really setting upon
and being happy with a
choice for an opera story.
Because it's something
you're going to live
with for quite a few years
of one's life and so you want
to make sure you've
made the right decision.
And so, after quite a bit of
deliberation and a fair bit
of daunting at the Shakespeare
factor, I decided to dive right
in and write not only a
Shakespeare opera, but Hamlet.
And I'm thrilled also
tonight that my librettist,
Matthew Jocelyn, is
here from Toronto.
Because he's been very much,
you know, my partner in crime
through this journey and it's
been an extraordinary thing
to delve into every single
word, not only of Hamlet
as we know it, but all
the different versions.
I mean Matthew brought into
play the early first quarto
and the differences between
the other versions as well
and so we've nutted out
our own version of Hamlet
over these past years
and the journey started
with the string quartet
that we'll hear tonight.
>> Anne McLean: Yeah,
I had wondered--
and I saw that you had--
you and Matthew had sat
down to read the entire
quarto in five hours
or something yourselves
to really hear every word.
I was fascinated to see on the
video that you talked about this
about just examining the
fragments and the phrases
and so forth and I
know that this piece--
tell us about the
string quartet.
You used words from other
people besides Ophelia.
>> Brett Dean: Well, Matthew's
idea then for this libretto,
in which we knew right from
the start we had one soprano,
it was obvious that we were then
going to examine one or other
of the female characters.
In a sense, we examined
both Ophelia and Gertrude,
but specifically Ophelia,
but not only her words,
but also words that are
said to her or about her or,
for example, Hamlet's love
poem that he writes to her.
In this way, we were able
to focus on various aspects
of this one person, but also
then start exploring other
characters as well and see
a kind of micro version
of the whole play
through the prism
of this one extraordinary
character.
>> Anne McLean: Well, it's in
June, right, at Glyndebourne?
>> Brett Dean: It premieres in
just a couple of months, yeah.
It's all very exciting.
>> Anne McLean: And we were
touched, really, to see--
to read about this, given that
our piece with the name Rooms
of Elsinore is about Hamlet's
potential or purported castle
and to realize that this brings
you to a sort of a full circle
of your passionate
endeavor to explore this.
Did you actually go to the
Kronborg castle I understand?
>> Brett Dean: Yeah.
In the midst-- fairly early
on in the journey, my wife,
Heather, who is also
here tonight,
she and I then paid a
visit to the Kronborg,
north of Copenhagen
on the strait
between Denmark and Sweden.
And whilst I know
that the director
of the Glyndebourne production,
the Australian director Neil
Armfield, isn't planning
on it being a period costume
drama, it was still fascinating
to walk through this space,
also accompanied by the thought
that we never-- you never know,
he may have been there himself
as a traveling player.
There were lots of
performances there at the time.
And just to get a feel for
how the unfolding of the play
in a physical space
could have happened.
And so, you know, in a way
this piece, Rooms of Elsinore,
is a kind of guided tour
of where the action takes place
following through the dark gate
of the beginning into
the king's chamber,
the chapel, the queen's chamber.
And it was also a nice
and I think fitting way
of closing the book on an
almost four-year journey
through Hamlet.
>> Anne McLean: Amazing that
it has been four years for you.
Do you feel-- do you feel
that you-- well, let me say--
take a step back on that.
I notice you talk about
literature as a huge influence
and you've talked
about a sense of place.
Would you mind saying what the
programmatic titles of the--
something about the
spaces and so on?
Because I found them-- listening
to your rehearsal work,
I found them very evocative and
very different from each other,
even though I didn't know the
program per se, I didn't think
about them, but, yeah, they
were-- they were fascinating.
And also then could
we talk a little
about the role of the piano too?
The piano writing.
>> Brett Dean: Yeah,
well, that will be for you
to say a few words
about, not-- I'll--
>> Anne McLean: Since
he plays, yeah.
>> Brett Dean: Well, I mean,
having taken quite a few photos
from the Kronborg
when we visited
and having them also placed
on my studio wall alongside
a long sort of storyboard
in shaping this opera, I
also had the tourist map
of the castle with, you know,
the numbered sort of highlights
of where you go through.
And so that's somehow what
brought about this idea
of the suite of seven movements
which open with the dark gate
and proceeds then
without a break
into the foregate courtyard.
The dark gates and the courtyard
and the following movement,
the platform, all relate
to material that I've used
in the opera that is the
moment where the ghost appears.
First of all, in the
original play, Horatio
and Marcellus see the ghost
and tell Hamlet about it later
and then, bam, he sees
the ghost himself,
which sets the whole
drama in motion.
We then proceed to
the fourth movement,
a long and very busy dramatic
movement called the king's
chamber, where obviously
so much of all that goes on
and all the intrigue in
the play takes place.
We then proceed to the chapel,
the place where Hamlet
chances upon Claudius
and actually sees an
opportunity to kill him
when Claudius is confessing
to the murder of King Hamlet.
Hamlet sneaks up behind
him, but then realizes
that seeing the king is
confessing his sin in church
to kill him there would
send him to heaven
and he doesn't want that.
He then proceeds from the
chapel to the queen's chamber
to confront his mother
about all that's going on,
having just witnessed the
play and being convinced
that what the ghost originally
told him must be true.
So, then the queen's
chamber is the other sort
of longish movement
which conjures this drama
of the ghost's reappearance
where hamlet sees the
ghost, but Gertrude doesn't.
Then, to close this particular,
you know, scene-setting piece
of seven movements,
I've proceeded then
to the trumpeter's tower, which
isn't a moment from the opera,
but gives us a kind of
birds-eye view of the whole--
you know, it's surveying
the area
in which the whole
play has taken place.
>> Anne McLean: This is
great because on the video
that we'll be connected to
tonight's perform-- we will--
we will put this together
and that way people will have a
chance to really hear what was
in your mind as you
worked through this
and I'd wondered too if your
wife's paintings had-- were--
have they been in this
storyline at any point?
I know you're influenced
by the lot of them.
>> Brett Dean: Very much
right from the start.
While I was still
humming and hawing
about whether I could possibly
take on Hamlet, Heather picked
up the ball and ran with it and
started a cycle of paintings,
which is also still ongoing
and she'll also be doing
two exhibitions in the U.K.
at the same time
as the production.
One in Glyndebourne itself
on the walls of the theater
and the other in London.
So, very-- I mean it's a--
it's a creative relationship
between us that is, you know,
charged by what the
other is up to, really.
Yeah.
>> Anne McLean: That's
wonderful.
And so let's talk about
your relationship here too.
I was fascinated to see you
put this together this week
and having found out that you
didn't know each other before,
what has that been like
where you're totally new
to each other and so on?
>> Brett Dean: We're
having a great time, but--
>> Juho Pohjonen: Likewise.
>> Brett Dean: You can say.
>> Juho Pohjonen:
Well, I mean-- the--
I got the music about
a month ago, which is--
I mean it sounds pretty short
time to put together something,
but actually it's a lot of time.
And we went through a few
revisions of the score
and we made some changes.
Even today you made
some changes.
>> Anne McLean: Really?
Oh, wow.
>> Juho Pohjonen: Of
course, first thing is
to just practice separately
the different parts
and then we met together two
days ago, three days ago?
Two days ago?
>> Brett Dean: Well,
what's today?
Saturday? We'd met--
we started on Thursday.
>> Juho Pohjonen: Right.
>> Anne McLean: And I'm so
glad you've almost had a mini
residency this week, in a way,
and thanks to David Pylar,
my colleague who had
shown you those treasures,
it's a way of sort
of introducing you
to the larger picture
of the library
and you got a mini
tour and so on.
But often artists come in
and we don't have the
time to spend with them.
So, it's pretty exciting
for us about this.
About the writing for the
work the Rooms of Elsinore,
I was going to ask you about--
we can talk a little bit about
the viola too and then I want
to get back to sort of new
music as a final topic.
But about the writing for
this one, you've mentioned
that you thought this
viola, the Tuscan Medici,
was especially perhaps a good
match because of its finesse,
the variety of things,
and this fast response.
I remember you said those
words, fast response,
and then I noticed there are
a lot of textures and so on.
And in your score you
say the word whisper
at one point I think.
Some things like that.
Did you find that this viola
helped you to express some
of those things that
you had in your mind?
>> Brett Dean: Well, I
mean a great instrument--
is a great instrument because
it can give you so much
because it has such a
wide palette of colors
and the tricky thing is
getting to know an instrument
of that quality in such
a short time, but--
and originally I was actually
thinking I'd play the shoe man
on the Stradivarius and my
piece on my own instrument,
but it was just so immediate
the relationship we struck
up that I thought, no, I mean,
get a chance to play on a Strad
of that quality, no, I
wouldn't mind one, really, but,
yeah, it's very special.
>> Anne McLean: Well,
this one, as many people
in the audience tonight will
know, is on loan to the library.
It's a special one made in 1690.
It's very powerful and has
a great, deep register.
It really sings.
It speaks.
You know? And I wanted to
talk about that a little bit.
Before we leave your
piece, Juho,
any comments on the
piano writing?
>> Juho Pohjonen:
The piano writing.
I just play the music
and hope for the best.
>> Anne McLean: Oh, my goodness.
>> Juho Pohjonen: What I
appreciate about your writing is
that the piano and viola, they
are pretty much equal in terms
of the importance, so there's
lots of things happening
on the piano and
also in the viola.
And, of course, because of
the different characteristics
of the instruments, the
viola has more melody
because that's what string
players can play only one line
and piano has more texture and
the texture is kind of something
that creates color
and atmosphere.
So, in a way, I have plenty of
things to do and have affect on.
>> Brett Dean: He's in charge
of the spooky bits, really.
>> Anne McLean: There are some
spooky bit-- there really are--
and you'll be-- it'll be great
to have a recording of this too.
There's ethereal
wisps here and there.
Yeah, and I can see, you know,
things floating in the air
above the ramparts and
things like that maybe.
I liked your piece--
this comment about this piece
having a dramaturgy of its own.
So, it's programmatic, but
you don't need the program
to hear it and understand it.
>> Brett Dean: Yeah, I'm
always fascinated by, you know,
how music comes across,
particularly new music,
if you don't know
anything about it.
You know, you sort of
turn on the radio and come
in to the middle of a piece
and what does that say to you.
And I do always hope
that the piece of music--
although, most of my
pieces have some sort of--
not necessarily program, but
extramusical aspect or component
to them, I like to think that
they will also make sense
on purely musical abstract
terms, if you like.
And so, you know,
I'd like to think
that the piece has its own
charge and fascination aside
from the titles of
the movements.
>> Anne McLean: Which
it certainly does
and you will enjoy
this piece very much.
Well, as segueing into just
new music, since that is
such a strong aspect at Santa
Fe and both here, what--
do you see any sort of--
not resurgence, but I feel
there's a lot more new music
being written for the viola
these days that's just
really excellent.
What is your perspective
on that?
It used to be sort of a
poor stepchild in a way.
>> Brett Dean: Well, because
the-- I mean violas are--
we're the slow ones, and so
we've been slow on the uptake
at developing our own repertoire
or at least composers
have neglected the viola
for such a long time
that it's now coming
into its own in many ways.
I mean in the later
sort of 20th century
and into the 21st century
it's really being recognized
for its own-- on its own terms.
It's not a violin.
It's not a cello.
It's very much its own thing and
has a very distinctive color.
And I mean it's also through
the commissioning process
of festivals such as yours,
Steve, that has sort of brought
about a lot of these
opportunities also,
the double viola quintet
of mine, just to speak
of my own things, but also no
doubt many other things as well.
And so, you know, it is-- it
is finding its repertoire.
And we don't have the
kind of, you know,
the legacy of umpteen Mozart or
Beethoven sonatas to fall back
on and so it's still--
it's still happening now.
>> Anne McLean: I think so.
Do you have-- have you had
any new pieces that are--
you'd like to mention that have
come along for you in this--
>> Steven Ovitsky: Well,
this summer, festival goes
between the 16th of July and
the 21st of August and during
that time we have
about 45 concerts
in just under six weeks.
Some weeks-- it's almost
like your schedule here,
but some weeks we have as many
as seven concerts in a week
and about 80 to 100 musicians
usually come to the festival.
And this summer we
have three new pieces,
the one you'll be hearing
tonight that we co-commissioned
with Anne and the
Library of Congress.
A piece for a piano
solo by Julian Anderson
that was co-commissioned
with the Aldeburgh Festival,
and a piece by Bill
Balkum [assumed spelling].
William Balkum, a sextet
for mixed wind, strings,
and piano that we
co-commissioned
with Chamber Music
Northwest in Portland.
And that's-- that should be--
I'm really looking forward
to hearing that one as well
because a few years ago
we were talking with Bill
and with David Shifrin,
the clarinetist who's
the artistic director
of Chamber Music Northwest, and
we were talking about what kind
of interesting, you know,
interesting orchestration
could we do.
And we had just played
Martinu's Revue de Cuisine,
which is like violin,
cello, trumpet, bassoon,
piano, and I think clarinet.
But-- and Bill said
that's a great combination.
So, he wanted to do that
and then, unfortunately,
after we had planned the season,
he said what would happen
if I changed the orchestration
to the same orchestration
as Walton's Facade?
>> Anne McLean: Oh, my goodness.
>> Steven Ovitsky: And
we were already locked in
and we couldn't do it and
the more I think about it--
I love the orchestration
of Facade
and it would be a great piece,
so maybe that will be
another time with Bill
because he loves writing
pieces that are very agreeable
to the audiences and
also have such cleverness
in the orchestration
and the composition.
So, those are three
new pieces this summer.
And we have commissions
for summer of 18 and summer
of 19 we're working on
now, so we're always doing
about three new works
every summer.
>> Anne McLean: Wonderful.
>> Steven Ovitsky: Yeah,
both co-commissions
and single commissions.
>> Anne McLean: And, Juho,
do you do a lot of new music
or is your performing
career mostly--
>> Juho Pohjonen: I do
every kind of music, but I--
>> Anne McLean: Wonderful, yeah.
>> Juho Pohjonen:
I'll play very--
in a short time is Esa-Pekka
Salonen's piano concerto,
which is very--
>> Anne McLean: I'm
a Salonen fan, yeah.
Fantastic.
>> Juho Pohjonen: Very
interesting music, too.
>> Anne McLean: And what's the
recording project you mentioned
that you're going back to?
>> Juho Pohjonen: Oh,
that's old music, Bach.
>> Anne McLean: That's
a nice mixture.
>> Brett Dean: Timeless.
>> Anne McLean: So,
one of the things
that while you were talking,
Steve, I was thinking
about Kim Kashkashian's
comment that she felt music--
new music for the viola was
more supported in Europe
and I said why would you--
why do you say that and she said
she thought there were still
government subsidy enough
for orchestras there
that you found the odd concerto
coming through because of that.
And you of course have
an orchestra background
and I hadn't thought of
that being a strong element
and why there might be more
viola pieces for orchestra now.
And you'd conduct your
own work a great deal.
You have more than one concerto?
>> Brett Dean: Well, I've
written myself a viola concerto.
I've got other concertos, but,
yeah, the viola concerto format
or genre is something that
I think has led the charge
of new repertoire
for the viola and--
I mean it's a tricky--
it's a tricky beast.
The viola-- in saying that
it's certainly not the violin
or the cello, it also sits
very much in the middle
of an orchestral range and so
scoring for it is something,
you know, in a concerto
setting is something you've got
to be a bit careful about.
I know I've had to rewrite
my own concerto a few times
because I couldn't be heard.
So, you know, you live
and learn, really.
>> Anne McLean: Well,
I know that we--
I think we need to give you
a chance to warm up on stage,
so do we-- I would love
to talk more and, in fact,
we'll have to have
offline conversations
about have you seen the
Benedict Cumberbatch Hamlet
and have you seen the
David Tennant Hamlet
and a few other things
like that.
But we want to give
the audience a chance.
So, does anyone have a question
for our colleagues here?
>> One second.
One second.
>> It's on?
OK. Actually, Anne,
this is additional.
I walked in when you made
the comments on Gershwin
and Schoenberg and I wanted
to add something to that
because I understand not
only did Gershwin subscribe
to the publication of
the Schoenberg quartets,
he helped finance recordings
of them in the 1930's
by the Kolisch Quartet, which I
think can still be found on CD
in the secondary market.
And they played tennis together
in Los Angeles regularly.
There's a clip of them playing--
>> Anne McLean: Tennis,
you said?
>> Yes. Yes, they enjoyed
playing tennis with each other.
There's a clip that can be seen
on YouTube of them doing this.
>> Anne McLean: Oh, my goodness.
>> And not only did Gershwin
greatly respect Schoenberg,
but it went the other way too.
Schoenberg had great respect
for Gershwin as a composer.
When Gershwin died in 1937,
there was a memorial book put
out of reminiscences
and Schoenberg's is one
of the most touching in
the whole collection.
And I believe there's
even a recording
of him reading a section
of it also on YouTube.
So, we draw this hard line
sometimes between tonal
and serial twelve tone music.
It-- the-- sometimes they're
a lot closer than we--
>> Brett Dean: And
some poses don't see it
as a hard line and-- which
brings me back to my comment
about the second quartet.
It's not a hard line,
it's actually--
it floats from one end to the
other and I think that's what's
so remarkable about
that piece too.
>> That's it.
Thanks.
>> Anne McLean: Yeah,
interesting.
Anyone else?
I think-- so, I think
we're in good shape.
Brett is going to give our viola
a little bit of a warm up here
and thank you very, very
much, Brett, Juho, Steve.
>> Brett Dean: Thank you.
It's been a pleasure.
[ Applause ]